hi guys my name is Tamara chambers and
this is Tamara's never seen today I was
filming nostalgia critic and I played a
lot of different characters and I took
makeup on and off and I looked like I've
been scrubbing my face with a sponge all
day she's basically the aesthetic I'm
going for so it's just a bun flip bun
flip tonight I am watching The Exorcist
for the first time all the way through
in high school I started watching it
with some friends Frank and Andy and we
watched I think it was then we watched
for I think the first 20 minutes and
then we turn it off because it was like
a dig site excavation in Egypt and we
had no interest in it so tonight I'm
gonna watch the full thing for the first
time
very excited realizing some high school
dreams tonight guys let's do it Oh
Tanner has never seen
time towba fest solid let's just jump
right in and I am going to skip right
over that first excavation dig scene
because who cares who cares about that
scene I got to the end of the movie and
I appreciated it because of the builds
that it gave but gosh dang Almighty
alive that was so boring so you see
Chris the mom the actress and you see
her daughter Regan very cute little girl
on girl team their mother and daughter
so this movie just this incredible build
to the end where if you just jump to it
like a lot of possession movies do you
don't get the story and then the scary
parts aren't scary because it's like
okay well whatever she's possessed big
whoop not a sentence I've ever said
before whereas in this movie you get a
lot of story oh no it's too much story
but not not it's it's perfect it just
takes a second to get into it but you
see the Ouija board scene and you see
howdy doody nope try again Tamara
captain howdy and then that ends up
being the demon that's possessing her
and by this point you've met the father
Damian who has a very depressing life
and he says that he's lost his faith and
his mother is in this insane asylum
because they can't afford a real
hospital and she dies and it's super
it's like a super heartbreaking and it's
a motion that you get in like a dramatic
film it's not a motion that you normally
get in like a scary movie yet at least
not done well cut to a bunch of rich
people at a party regan sleepwalks
downstairs says you're all gonna die up
there and then pees your pants then her
bed starts rocking and none the good way
so Chris takes her to the doctor
obviously and the doctors like it's a
lesion in her brain because doctors know
everything what so they do this painful
spinal tap I think on Regan and they
don't find anything on her brain which
stresses me out because tests on tests
on tests for anyone but especially a
child when it's painful like that oh
that is like a very eye
using this word this is like a very
triggering it makes you very I don't you
use Network whatever it is it makes me
uncomfortable but course calls the
doctors because Regan is going crazy and
she's like flailing in her bed and the
doctors come and Regan starts yelling oh
that Regan bitch slaps the crap out of
the doctor space it's it's it's an
impressive slap and the doctor trying to
piece it together like what could it be
he's like are there drugs in the house
and Chris is like no he's like are you
sure and she's like yes I'm sure I don't
even smoke grass well there is a time
and place for everything and girl habits
there's a lot of sexual elements to
Regan's possession for a movie that was
made in the time that it was made I
think it's it must have been extremely
shocking to see this in theaters I mean
the scary elements aside like just the
sexual aspects like she gets hypnotized
Regan gets hypnotized and she grabs the
hypnotists crotch and then later she
finds a crucifix in her bed and she's
like stabbing her vagina with it and
then she like pushes Chris's face on it
it's intense but I feel like current
movies that are like horror films that
are just trying to give you like a shock
thing this may be because of that like
I'm be sensitized but this doesn't feel
like that this feels like it's it's done
in a way that's not like shocked it's
done in a way that's like oh this is no
good you know what I don't know if that
makes any sense but it just it feels
like it's well done versus just like
maybe if we shock him enough it'll be
scary and interesting artful so Chris
meets up with the father and she tries
not to tell him about Regan at first
it's like a very casual conversation
like Oh how's the weather did you have a
sandwich for lunch how do you perform an
exorcism what the father explains to her
that since they've learned about mental
illness and science that exorcisms
aren't generally performed anymore and
while I love love the emphasis there's a
lot of emphasis on mental illness and
scientific research in this movie it's
about time to perform an exorcism on
this crippled chop-chop I mean your
mother sucks oh let's do
I mean come on it's time say no I'm
weirdly attracted to the priest so take
that as you will
so Damien goes to see Regan and that's
when she throws up the green split pea
soup that I've heard so much about my
whole life exorcism split pea soup hand
in hand and he weirdly doesn't think
that she's possessed yet and I admire
his hesitancy to not do an unnecessary
and potentially harmful exorcism but one
of the first parts in the movie that
scared me versus it just being an
uncomfortable moment is Damien Records
her speaking a different language and he
brings it to another priestess like this
is is this cause for an exorcism the
priest is like no because it's English
it's just in Reverse and he plays it
back and there's something really creepy
about English in Reverse also what she
was saying was super scary like give her
time to die fear the priest let us kill
her it was that's horrifying that's so
so scary also the makeup and effects are
dated but still dated in a good way it
doesn't take me out of being scared so
that's so that means they hold up
literally the definition so they decide
that this priest named Marin should do
the exorcism and oh shit that's the guy
who's digging up shit in Egypt and
taking names in the beginning things
matched up whoa they perform the
exorcism and there's so much I can say
about it but really what I took from the
whole scene is not many horror films can
give you such a scary scene without jump
scares it's like it's like this
lingering fear versus cheap crap just
little things like there's intense cold
breath coming up the whole time and it's
a slow build into it it is the best
possession movie I have ever seen and I
know it's the original so is the
possession movie so Damien is in there
and the demon is talking as his dead
mother
to Damian saying that it's his fault
that she died and talking in Greek which
is obviously a language that Regan
doesn't know so he leaves to catch his
breath and he comes back in and Marin is
dead and the demon is just sitting there
on the bed like oh there's a finger the
demon is just sitting from the bed like
what up what up playa
so Damian freaks out it starts beating
up Regan and it's like take me take me
instead to the demon which was it was so
intense and and so the demon enters
Damian he resists it and he's like no no
no and he just jumps out a window and
Josh and Chris walks in she's like not
sure and she's like sees her child eyes
for the first time in a long time and
like goes in hugs her it's very intense
and so good it was it was so it was so
good I cannot believe that I waited this
long like back to the future whatever
Jurassic Park fine but I love scary
movies and so it's so weird that I
haven't seen this one because I complain
all the time that there aren't any scary
movies that are good that I can watch
for the first time like I've seen all
the good ones listen this is a good a
ton of crap that I just have no interest
in seeing at all and this that was like
new content for me to watch and like
devour was so good what are the most
unnerving aspects were for me was Chris
having to be in this house with this
demon for so long there was such this
long process of figuring out what was
wrong with her there's a lesion on her
head is she you know possessed does she
die I don't know how long do you think
it is months a month a couple weeks to
live with a demon in your house and now
I just want to watch a bunch of scary
movies so please comment with your
favorite scary movie because I just need
more scary content oh I have such a huge
surprise for you guys I'm so excited
right now almost forgot
he's so comfy how you doing is that too
bright I'm sorry I'm so sorry
SOP okay okay okay all right
he's so mad at me I'm covered in cat
hair now see you next week
you
okay um so let me say this out loud just
so that we're clear you want me to do
hair flips lots of hair flips bring a
minimum of two cats and say love a lot
okay I very excited to be in the next
Tamara's never seen this is very
exciting
yes I am I am very excited yes
I love it yes I love you I love
everything everything is wonderful great
excellent fantastic awesome great by God
the things I do to keep Tamara happy she
better do a lot of goofy shit in the
next behind-the-scenes